so freely sphere here thanks Evelyn
thanks out like that either damage my
neck on my fanny I've got to choose
between it's cool when we go next
Topsy convent forward so for God's sake
nobody in the front row do anything
interesting because she shall be no
carriage we can no more in or tearing
we've had enough of that tonight and to
say nothing of the 19th ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for that
extremely tolerant welcome it's fabulous
to be here indeed anywhere I hope that
you're enjoying your night and drinking
dry the bar and it's time now for some
music which is of course why we're here
ninety-eight percent of the female DJs
on British radio drink offense yeah this
is it pretty much we're hit celebrate
when the greatest acts in pop history
take take yourselves back no to a time
where a Spice Girl - just a twinkle in
their managers eye to the time when well
before one direction were even an
erection that is right as an image we
are we're picturing it server thank you
very much yes
back in 1979 the teenagers you were
living in a squat above Malcolm McLaren
bookshops X decided to form a band their
sound and star would go on to shape the
decade that followed for a generation of
pop fans from it ain't what you do to
really saying something I heard a rumor
to love in the first degree yes Lauren
cruel summer to Venus these Punk's turn
pop princesses have non-stop chart
Spanglish and iconic DIY fashions done
yes absolutely and their success on both
the pop and dance charts has earned them
a listing in the Guinness Book of
Records as the all-female group with the
most chart entries in the world we do
our fireworks annoyed for that and also
a tennis club that is correct
break I'm enjoying this night that's
what not without doubt they fade away
they influence every girl band you can
think of you know Spice Girls Girls
Aloud Little Mix all of them no suit
Siobhan left 30 years ago we've all been
waited a little bit like Robert De
Niro's clue that for them to get back
together the original lineup a but
they've made our dreams come true this
year late one of the year they go in a
big nationwide tour and we bloody love
them yeah yes yes we sing like about
this year's it gets glamour I crumbs out
of three in a million Bananarama only
one award I'll take that at least we've
got one thank you so much I don't think
we've ever received award before so it
was truly truly great with her glamour
as I said we were teenagers when we
started it didn't think we'd still
continue to this day but we have we've
had an amazing career
weezing without shovel but now she's
back with us for a tour at the end of
the year the response has been
overwhelming by the public and the media
and we just can't wait to get out there
and this is like the icing on the cake
thank you I think when we were told we
were getting an icon award I just
thought what but in this last round of
publicity I can't tell you how many
women I've met in really strong
successful positions who said oh my god
you are my idol growing up and we
followed your lead and and it was in the
80s where particularly our business was
so male led and dominated what thank you
very much can I not say anything do you
have to be all on I mean II knew news 4
at what John and Jen like to join in
anyway you get my chair yeah I normally
just take the piss out of my son every
Street on me anyway I hope that if we
see that anything is this always be true
to yourself and follow your heart
whatever you dream you can do so just
begin it we did and we're still here
thank you